Now you've done this already, remember? When you changed all of the pixels from
an image into the negative. At the time, I gave you the loop structure to do
this, and I told you not to look too closely at it. Now, we're ready to reveal
this mystery. On your left we're going to start this program. We have a full
loop. Because we want to iterate over all of the pixels, we'll find out soon
enough how many pixels there are. The structure's very similar to the structure
for working with words. Instead of getting the ith character, we get the ith
pixel by getting the color at position i. And we can also set it, presumably
after having changed it in some way. So here's your basic loop. Get the pixel,
process it, and put it back. Now, how many pixels do we have? We can ask the
picture, and it's going to tell us the number of pixels. And that is the exact
analogue to the length of a string except that you should think of the pixels
as being arranged like this. A row of pixels, another row and they all come one
after another. When we ask for them. And eventually we reach all the pixels
that way. I starts at zero. It goes up to the total pixel count. Is incremented
at every step. We get the i pixel. And that way we get all of the pixels in the
image. In our particular example. We simply compute the negative of the color,
and then we can put it back. Finally, we want to load the picture, show it to
the user, and then start processing it. Let's run the code. Here is Eliza, all
positive. And here she is, sadly negative. As you've seen, it's just as easy to
work with pictures as it is to work with words.